pour Loïc senior manifestation et
mouvement de grève dans les raffineries
on voit que ça s'étend au centrales
nucléaires est-ce que le gouvernement
avait sous-estimé le climat social non
je crois pas qu'il est sous-estimé le
climat social ça fait un certain nombre
de mois maintenant que des organisations
syndicales préviennent notamment dans
leur branche respective les entreprises
et nous on est attaché à quoi au
dialogue social dans l'entreprise on le
répète suffisamment depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant on a demandé nous
l'augmentation des salaires on a dit il
faut que les entreprises jouent le jeu
il y a cette inflation certes c'est la
mieux contenu d'Europe en France on l'a
vu ce sont des données officielles mais
il y a cette inflation elle est réelle
et les entreprises doivent jouer le jeu
c'est le cas de total c'est le cas de
nombreuses entreprises regardées par
exemple dans le secteur de l'aérien Air
France joue avec une prime de 1000 euros
pour pour ses salariés donc il y a cette
situation nous ce qu'on souhaite
simplement c'est qu'elle ne dégénère pas
elle ne dégénère pas dans la rue hier il
y a eu encore des interpellations des
violences il faut aussi que les
mouvements politiques qui appellent
parfois dans des mots assez étranges
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a appelé à
marcher sur l'Elysée avant sa grande
marche du 16 octobre il faut qu'il y ait
une responsabilité collective et qu'on
ne soit pas responsable si responsable
les mots de Jean-Luc Mélenchon était
particulièrement irresponsables ça c'est
plutôt bien passé dimanche dans une
manifestation en demi-temps ce n'était
pas un grand succès pour la France
insoumise il y a il y avait peu de gens
dans la rue mais malgré tout il y a des
violences et ça on peut le regretter et
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer les
l'action des forces de l'ordre hier qui
ont permis justement que le débat puisse
quelque part avoir lieu aussi dans la
rue sans trop de casse ni de violence je
suis étonné de de ces bourreaux puisque
j'ai entendu le préfet de Paris monsieur
Nunez dire hier justement qu'il était il
se satisfaisait justement de de la bonne
réussite des deux dernières
mobilisations avec très peu d'incidents
un incident remarquable parce que une je
crois c'est une c'est une banque qui a
été vandalisée mais il se félicitait de
la bonne tenue de ces manifestations
donc je trouve surprenante que vous
reteniez oui aussi d'ailleurs monsieur
Nunez à saluer l'organisation de la CGT
et son savoir-faire de de gestion de
cortège donc bon moi je veux que je veux
bien entendre que il soit préférable
pour vous parler des violences plutôt
que de parler de la raison pour laquelle
les gens étaient mobilisés hier mais il
faut quand même se dire que certes
c'était pas un énorme succès c'était pas
massif c'est comme le dirait libération
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui a
avoir avec un avertissement qui donnait
au gouvernement
anticiper le gouvernement anticiper il y
a quand même un
problème au démarrage on a bien vu
qu'aujourd'hui le propos qui était celui
de Monsieur Véran qui expliquait qu'il y
avait pas de pénurie aujourd'hui on est
forcé de conserver qu'il y a quand même
des pénuries donc forcément qu'il y
avait pas de la part du gouvernement ils
avaient pas pris la mesure peut-être de
ce qui était en train d'arriver de ce
qui est en train de se passer et ce
qu'il a peut-être continué de se passer
parce qu'on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui il
y a les mobilisations politiques
mobilisation citoyen mobilisation
syndicale mobilisation salariés et on
voit qu'aujourd'hui ces forces là ont
plutôt envie de discuter ensemble à
l'organisation de mobilisation qui
serait des mobilisations unitaires je
sais pas si ça arrive vraiment en tout
cas il y a ce sentiment que ça ne peut
plus être chacun de son côté et pour
faire pression auprès du gouvernement je
pense que c'est sain et c'est bien que
politique intellectuel mouvement social
se coalise pour pouvoir faire porter un
message beaucoup plus fort vis-à-vis du
gouvernement j'entends la volonté et
sans doute était le vrai de vouloir
discuter forcément qu'aujourd'hui il y a
un blocage et d'ailleurs
je trouve assez gonflé d'ailleurs
souvent on dit souvent que la CGT la
pour bloquer etc il faut quand même se
rappeler vous le savez sans doute que la
CGT signe entre 60 et 80% des accords
d'entreprise chaque année ce qui est
quand même pas rien et ça veut dire
aussi qu'on a une vie démocratique dans
les entreprises qui se passent pas trop
mal on va on va revenir sur deux choses
un d'abord les seigneur je vous laisse
répondre sur ce qu'a dit Pierre sur le
gouvernement et sous-estimé il y a trop
tarder à réagir et puis après on
reviendra sur justement c'est que le
gouvernement à l'origine de cette crise
n'est pas partie prenante le
gouvernement a des échanges Elisabeth
borne avec Monsieur poulianet le patron
de Total et on lui dit qu'il va y avoir
discussion donc déjà c'est la première
pierre qui est posée par le gouvernement
on dit il faut vous mettre autour de la
table c'est fait cette négociation cette
négociation a lieu non mais je rappelle
les fait simplement c'est une
négociation a lieu la CGT en sort alors
que un accord majoritaire a été trouvé
malgré ça la CGT continue de bloquer la
CGT n'est pas majoritaire
Laurent Berger dit on va pas se remettre
à la table de négociation on a voté bon
alors comment on forme la CGT de revenir
autour de la table et d'accepter et de
négocier pas d'accepter de négocier
simplement s'ils veulent aller plus loin
c'est leur droit la revendication de la
CGT des salariés de la CGT et légitime
ils ont le droit de demander des
augmentations de salaire mais à partir
du moment où un accord majoritaire a été
trouvé il faut peut-être non pas rentrer
dans le rang mais trouver un compromis
avec les autres acteurs je le rappelle
la CGT n'est pas majoritaire chez Total
énergie donc la CGT aujourd'hui toute
seule a décidé de bloquer pour diverses
raisons et notamment internes des
élections syndicales notamment a décidé
de bloquer des millions de Français dans
les stations services et ça ce n'est pas
normal pardonnez-moi de vous le dire il
faut rejoindre la mobilisation résultats
pour des raisons internes à la CGT donc
ça veut dire que quand même quelque
chose aussi
et bien sûr interne comme tous les
syndicats et il y a pas un agenda
politique au gouvernement il y a pas un
agent de la politique au modem il y a
pas un agenda
tout le monde politique donc il faut pas
nier quand même les les les deux
politiques et non pas non plus pour des
raisons politiser ça veut dire vous
savez quand on prend l'exemple de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui blocage de Total ça
pénalise tout le monde total il pénalise
à la fois les salariés mais à la fois
les usagers avec le coup des le coup de
l'essence aujourd'hui donc ce que je
veux dire c'est que il faut arrêter de
mettre tout le dos sur le sur le sur le
sur les grévistes qui serait des
méchants bloqueurs aujourd'hui la
question c'est pas que total c'est la
question des salaires vous dites
aujourd'hui le gouvernement s'est engagé
à faire en sorte que les salariés soient
mieux payés mais quel instrument
mettez-vous à disposition pour
contraindre des entreprises à payer
mieux les salariés mais c'est pourquoi
le gouvernement
donné dans l'histoire de notre pays vous
n'êtes pas vous êtes bien conscient que
dans l'histoire d'un pays quand il y a
eu des volontés politiques mais le
gouvernement était là pour mettre autour
de la tablette syndicale le patrimoine
pour discuter de l'évolution des
salaires
les entreprises à trouver le jeu à se
mettre
vous le savez très bien c'est des
incitations c'est aussi cette entreprise
ce mécanisme sur les supers
l'Union européenne jusqu'au au droit
commun français vous le savez nous avons
mis en place cette axe mécanisme sur les
super profits qui justement va viser les
énergies fossiles ça c'est une manière
aussi de répondre à la crise dont
profite quelque part total évidemment
mais aussi à l'enjeu écologique de dire
voilà nous on va mettre une taxe sur les
super profits sur les énergies fossiles
ça c'est pour faire comprendre à Total
qu'ils doivent jouer le jeu à la fois de
la crise énergétique et de la crise
financière que l'on vit à travers
l'inflation donc nous incitons mais le
gouvernement pardon on n'est pas membre
du conseil de surveillance de Total pas
plus que d'autres entreprises privées le
gouvernement lui agit sur les salaires
qu'il paye à la fin du mois sur les
fonctionnaires sur le budget que nous
essayons de voter pour augmenter le
nombre de fonctionnaires pour de
policiers de gendarmes pour augmenter le
salaire des professeurs à partir de 2023
ça c'est des leviers qui appartiennent à
la majorité totale nous incitons
Elizabeth borne le président de la
République incite les les représentants
de Total à discuter avec leurs salariés
c'est ce qui a été fait malheureusement
la CGT ne veut toujours pas accepter ces
discussions bon j'entends que le
gouvernement ne peut pas tout que la
politique ne peut pas tout que les
choses doivent se passer à l'échelle des
entreprises et pourquoi pas la limite
c'est vrai que le dialogue social est
plus sain et plus simple quand il se
fait l'échelle de l'entreprise vous
savez vous comme moi qu'aujourd'hui la
majorité des salariés sont des deux
entreprises il y a pas de représentants
directs des salariés que donc la
négociation pour les salaires a toujours
un peu plus compliqué donc quand il y a
pas de volonté politique d'impulser une
dynamique ou en tout cas une évolution
notable des salaires il ne se passe rien
s'il n'y a pas de volonté et on l'a vu
le gouvernement l'a fait d'aider des
entreprises sans qu'il y ait des
contreparties sur la question sociale ou
sur les questions écologique il ne se
passe rien donc l'état le gouvernement
s'est appliquer des mesures qui sont des
mesures contraignantes quand il s'agit
par exemple aller d'aller casser du
grévis ou en mettant en réquisitionné
caricatures à peine c'est-à-dire qui
sait être ferme non mais il sait être
ferme quand il s'agit de casser des
grèves de réquisitionner des entreprises
en revanche dès qu'il s'agit de mettre
un tout petit peu de points sur la table
pour faire en sorte que les entreprises
mettent la main à la poche pour aider
les salariés à s'en sortir mieux mais
pas que les salariés d'ailleurs pardon
mais il y a les minima sociaux c'est un
levier aussi lequel pour lequel le
gouvernement pourrait agir c'est-à-dire
augmenter les minima sociaux augmenter
le SMIC c'est une c'est un des
instruments que
vous l'avez remarqué ça suffit pas
aujourd'hui ça suffit jamais à un moment
donné il faut pas être trajectoire
budgétaire social mettez les gens autour
de la table et imposer aux gens de
discuter
cohérent sinon ce que vous décrivez ce
sont des hausses d'impôts pour les
entreprises et pour les particuliers et
le gouvernement s'est engagé ne pas
augmenter les impôts durant ce
quinquennat jusqu'en 2027 c'est quand
même
est-ce que là il va falloir passer à une
sortie politique est-ce que la sortie
politique ça peut être une grande
conférence salariale alors le président
de la République vous n'ignorez pas à
présenter le cadre d'un Conseil national
de la refondation on peut appeler ça
comme on veut les oppositions les
partenaires sociaux hormis quelques-uns
n'ont pas voulu y participer à chaque
fois que l'on dit on va se réunir autour
de la table on nous dit encore à
Grenelle encore une conférence encore
ceci et personne ne veut discuter les
oppositions qu'est-ce qu'elles font
elles disent en août on ne votera jamais
le budget aujourd'hui elle nous
répondent quoi vous ne voulez pas nous
écouter on va passer par le 49-3 oui
pardon nous on a ouvert le dialogue
jusqu'au bout la preuve jusqu'à
aujourd'hui il y a toujours pas de 49-3
donc l'opposition est dans son rôle mais
à un moment donné il faut arrêter de
sortir des postures et peut-être entamer
des compromis des discussions des
négociations mais qui profitent aux
Français c'est ce que nous nous disons
c'est ce qui sera sans doute la finalité
du budget parce qu'on va retenir
certains amendements de l'opposition on
va venir sur un peu plus tard il faut
s'asseoir autour d'une table je suis
d'accord d'accord mais encore faut-il
que tout le monde vienne et qu'il n'y
ait pas la politique de la chaise vide
voilà le problème de la Conférence
nationale de la refondation c'était
quand même que c'était un fourre-tout où
on allait discuter de tout et n'importe
quoi à la limite pourquoi pas on peut
discuter
non mais très bien qui est l'éducation
sur à peu près tout que le président
fasse une vidéo de 10 minutes pour
expliquer aux Français que chaque sujet
mérite que tout le monde se mette autour
d'une table que ce soit dans les écoles
que ce soit dans les hôpitaux pour
trouver des solutions à la limite
pourquoi pas mais vous convoquez des
syndicats demain et le patronat pour
faire une grande conférence salariale
organisée et en dessous la tutelle de
l'État mais je peux vous assurer que
demain tous les syndicats tous les
partis politiques tout le monde y va
enfin je veux dire il y a pas de sujet
si le sujet c'est celui la question
salariale ce que demande à peu près tout
le monde aujourd'hui dans le pays tout
le monde dira donc ne dit pas que
personne ne veut y participer parce que
aujourd'hui ce CNR c'est quand même un
truc un peu fourre-tout où on sait pas
très bien ce qu'il en sortira on sait
pas très bien comment tout ça va être
piloté même si c'est plutôt à l'échelle
des territoires et c'est plutôt bien que
ça se passe à l'échelle de ce qui se
passe concrètement sur le territoire
mais sur des sujets aussi sensibles que
celui des salaires qui a un sujet
quotidien et que ça attire les Français
dites pas qu'aujourd'hui si le président
de la République convoqué tout le monde
autour de la table pour discuter de la
des révolution de cet art personne
n'irait tout le monde dirait ça je peux
vous l'assurer encore faut-il qu'il y
reste un mot sur ce que disait pierre
tout à l'heure on en arrive au deuxième
point en fait il parlait de cette
convergence c'est vrai qu'il peut il
peut y avoir du fun il va y avoir
apparemment une discussion entre les
partis politiques et les syndicats
est-ce que vous la redoutez cette
convergence on parle toujours de
convergence on parle toujours de quoi de
coagulation ce sont aussi des craintes
de certains qui s'auto alimentent c'est
aussi
parfois diligenté par certains
mouvements politiques qui espèrent cette
convergence des luttes cette coagulation
des luttes aujourd'hui ce qu'on a vu
c'est qu'il n'y a pas forcément des
millions de Français dans la rue secteur
par secteur finir par filière il faut y
faire attention et encore une fois c'est
le sens de la politique menée par
Elisabeth borne c'est le dialogue le
compromis la négociation à l'Assemblée
nationale ici au Sénat il faut
évidemment changer la manière dont on
fait de la politique quand on est en
majorité relative personne le conteste
et il faut entendre les acteurs les
parties prenantes la coagulation ça
c'est les Français qui en décideront
hier ça ne s'est pas vu dans la rue
dimanche ça ne s'est pas vu non plus il
faut être prudent il faut être
extrêmement prudent de dimanche
d'une grève d'une manifestation et
encore une fois les salariés
la mobilisation politique je pense que
chacun a vu les images et ce n'a pas
effectivement eu le succès populaire
qu'espérait Jean-Luc Mélenchon on est
plus tôt dans un front un peu populaire
quand on voit les résultats dans les
sondages pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon
particulièrement depuis l'affaire katnas
qui a beaucoup choqué je crois les
militants de la France insoumise et plus
largement les Français et ceux qui
apprécient le débat politique quand il
est sain hier je n'ai pas encore une
fois jugé le succès ou l'échec d'une
manifestation mais je vois que les
français eux ont envie d'aller au
travail de gagner de l'argent que
l'inflation ne réduise pas leur niveau
de vie et pour ça nous on s'engage et on
s'engage par quoi par des mesures et par
ce qui s'est passé à l'été les 20
milliards de de de décider par
l'Assemblée nationale pour le pouvoir
d'achat et par le budget et encore une
fois j'appelle les oppositions à la
responsabilité aujourd'hui et par la
suite à voter des amendements qui vont
aussi dans un cadre budgétaire cohérent
parce que la France est regardée de
présence au point de vue la réponse de
pierre sur cette convergence avant de
passer au budget oui je pense qu'il y a
bien un enjeu il y a surtout une
responsabilité politique je parle pas de
vous parler de responsabilité des
oppositions mais encore faut-il être
responsabilité je veux c'est quand même
votre majorité c'est le parti politique
que vous représenter qui est quand même
en majorité et qui est quand même en
capacité de prendre des décisions donc
demander de la responsabilité des
oppositions elles font leur rôle les
oppositions et je trouve que là quand je
parle de responsabilité politique des
oppositions que ce soit les partis
politiques les syndicales les
associations les intellectuels c'est
qu'il y a il y a on voit bien que dans
l'opinion publique aujourd'hui il y a il
y a une volonté dans des ballons des
coups de mais en tout cas il y a une
critique massive quand même des
politiques qui sont menées et aussi de
l'absence de cohérence et de de de de on
a l'impression que la classe politique
pour les Français est totalement hors
sol par rapport à ce que est-ce qu'ils
vivent donc il y a une responsabilité je
pense il y a une attente en tout cas des
sympathisants de gauche des syndicats
des partis politiques des intellectuels
des associations à se mettre ensemble à
porter une voie commune qui puisse peser
vis-à-vis du gouvernement mais vous avez
raison vous laissez-vous même qu'il
l'avait dit c'est pas que des parties
c'est pas que des syndicats qui vont
décider c'est le peuple d'une manière
générale on a vu comment on va démarrer
un mouvement comme celui des gilets
jaunes c'est parti d'ailleurs des
politiques n'avaient pas la main
là-dessus ni les syndicats ni personne
donc je pense que la crise elle peut
elle ne peut prendre que si
effectivement à un moment donné il y a
un mouvement d'ampleur citoyen qui se
met en branle mais il faut aussi que les
syndicats sont fassent l'écho les partis
politiques sont facent l'écho que
d'autres forces de la société civile
sont pas aussi et on va parler du budget
puisque les débats poursuivent pour le
moment à l'Assemblée nationale mais de
selon toute vraisemblance le 49.3
devrait dégainé dans les prochaines
heures de quoi s'agit-il Audrey alors on
va faire un petit point historique à
8h40 un article qui a été voulu par le
général de Gaulle au moment du fondement
de la Cinquième République parce que la
quatrième était très instable les
gouvernements se succédaient sans cesse
et de Gaulle a voulu cet article pour
renforcer les pouvoirs et la stabilité
du gouvernement ça lui permet d'adopter
une loi sans passer par le Parlement
depuis 2008 on peut le faire sur trois
textes par session parlementaire une
fois pour le budget une fois pour le
budget de la Sécurité sociale et une
fois pour un autre texte beaucoup estime
qu'il s'agit d'une bombe atomique
législative et les gouvernements ne s'en
prive pas
le 49,3 a été déclenché 90 fois sous la
Cinquième concrètement comment ça se
passe le gouvernement déclenche
l'article après délibération en Conseil
des ministres les débats s'arrêtent
automatiquement le gouvernement reprend
la main sur le texte sur lequel il
engage sa responsabilité il peut s'il le
souhaite supprimer tous les amendements
qui ont déjà été ôtés normalement c'est
pas ce qui devrait être fait le texte
retenu est considéré comme adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale sauf si une motion
de censure est votée dans les 24 heures
par les députés dans ce cas le
gouvernement est forcé de démissionner
ça n'est jamais arrivé rien pourquoi
l'exécutif en arrive parce que le texte
sans Lise notamment 3300 amendements ont
été déposés il en reste plus de 1000 à
analyser une éternité mais aussi parce
que vous le savez il n'y a pas de
majorité absolue résultat le
gouvernement s'est fait dépasser à
plusieurs reprises lors de l'examen du
texte la taxe sur les super dividendes
par exemple a été adopté contre son avis
ça peut paraître un aperçu du vote final
le gouvernement préfère peut-être ne pas
prendre de risques d'autant que les
oppositions ont déjà prévenu dès cet été
elle ne voteront un budget comme
l'expliquer Bruno Retailleau le
président du groupe les républicains au
Sénat c'était lors de la rentrée des
jeunes républicains le problème c'est
que voter un budget parce que la
Cinquième République mais y compris dans
des collectivités locales c'est dessiner
une majorité c'est pas un acte comptable
un budget c'est avant tout un acte
politique sommes-nous oui ou non dans la
majorité présidentielle la réponse elle
est non elle est non non et non
si le 49-3 est déclenché le texte
arrivera ensuite au Sénat exactement et
on verra ça alors hier on a entendu le
x-ignor et les Abed banque qui accusait
les oppositions de blocage mais on a
entendu Bruno Le Maire dire que les
débats c'était bien passé qui avaient eu
des échanges sur le fond il y a pas un
peu une forme de contradiction
que vous avez passé de Bruno retaillod
c'est ça que les Français ne veulent pas
entendre c'est ça que les Français ne
comprennent pas c'est pas un acte
politique de voté un budget ou alors un
peu quand même vieille politique de
vieilles politiques les Français ils
sont moquent de savoir si c'est de la
politique ils veulent savoir s'ils
auront de l'argent à la fin du mois ils
veulent savoir s'ils vont bien vivre et
voter un budget c'est peut-être ça qui
est intéressant aujourd'hui en 2022 pour
les Français on n'est pas dans de la
logique politique politicienne comme on
aurait pu l'avoir par le passé voilà
déjà ce qui faut peut-être dire parce
que sinon effectivement ça ne sert à
rien d'avoir des des débats des
dialogues des négociations du compromis
effectivement Elisabeth borne a dit ceci
Bruno Le Maire a dit cela ils ne sont
pas dans le même rôle ils n'occupent pas
la même fonction pendant le maire a
passé des heures
encore à Bercy où il a présenté le
budget c'est inédit très tôt aux
oppositions puis en commission avec
Gabriel Attal le ministre des comptes
publics et il a vu effectivement un
certain nombre d'opposants amendés mais
amender de manière parfois c'est vrai
intelligente et cohérente et on va
reprendre des amendements de
l'opposition Elisabeth borne cette
fois-ci la annoncé après il faut rester
dans un cadre et ça c'est au
gouvernement dans des CD dans la vision
globale d'un budget il ne faut pas
dépasser il peut y avoir un très bon
amendement mais qui ne rentre pas dans
le budget qui est celui de la majorité
et qui sera le nôtre je l'espère dans
dans les prochaines dans les prochaines
heures parce qu'on est dans une
situation inédite de crise de crise
économique avec l'inflation de crise
énergétique il y a la guerre en Europe
qui qui menace bien évidemment donc il
faut être cohérent il faut avoir
effectivement des des armes pour nous
défendre surtout ces plans là et ça
passe par un budget cohérent avec des
amendements on l'espère de l'opposition
qui jusqu'au bout pourront nourrir cela
mais en restant évidemment dans dans un
cadre établi par le gouvernement parce
qu'à la fin c'est quand même le
gouvernement et la majorité qui décide
n'avait pas d'autres choix compte tenu
des positions de l'opposition qui c'est
vrai toutes les oppositions dit que de
toute façon de votre espace budget
d'abord dire qu'un budget est cohérent
c'est politique c'est à dire que
que vous soyez de gauche que vous soyez
droite vous construirez pas le même
budget n'importe quelle collectivité
construit un budget et chacun d'un côté
comme de l'autre de l'hémicycle décide
ou pas de s'emparer de ce budget qui
détermine si vous êtes dans la majorité
ou dans l'opposition après de libre à
vous effectivement une fois le votre
budget de ne pas voter un certain nombre
de délibérations qui sont qui sont
émises par une la majorité mais le
budget est éminemment politique c’est
d’ailleurs ce qui fabrique la politique
c'est ce qui donne les marges de Metz de
politique et là pourquoi sa cristallise
les tensions en ce moment-là c'est que
la partie du PLFSS qui est en train
d'être du PLF qui est en train de
discuter c'est la partie recette et
pourquoi la partie recette fait débat
c'est parce que Emmanuel Macron depuis
qu'il est en responsabilité depuis 2017
n'a eu de cesse que de retirer des
recettes dans les caisses de l'État
français ce qui est une volonté affichée
et assumer donc quand on décide de
retirer des recettes quand on décide de
retirer des que ce soit la taxe
d'habitation que ce soit l'exit tac que
ce soit la flat tax que ce soit
encore d'autres dispositifs parce qu'il
y a plus de je crois de 100 milliards
c'est 100 milliards de budgets en moins
dans les recettes de l'État depuis que
Emmanuel Macron est arrivé au pouvoir
c'est un objectif politique donc que sa
cristallise des débats au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est une évidence
mais dans le 49-3 pour moi s'il devait
être sorti aujourd'hui des des de la
part du gouvernement ce serait la
première ça serait d'abord et avant tout
le résultat d'un échec du gouvernement à
partir du moment où lui-même a affiché
dès lors de la prélever législative que
il chercherait les voies du compromis
les voies des discussions possibles pour
que on puisse trouver à chaque fois sur
chaque texte la possibilité d'un
compromis bon bah là visiblement il y a
pas de
compromisent que le budget c'est
politique et qu'elle ne voteront pas
trouvé je pense qu'à minima moi c'est ma
grande conviction depuis toujours c'est
qu'il y a un jeu de dupe aujourd'hui
avec à droite qui consiste à dire la
droite n'est pas d'accord avec la
macronie alors que la macronie de droite
enfin je veux dire avec à ça près je
veux dire les les enjeux les
orientations sont à peu près les mêmes
donc a priori je vois pas pourquoi la
droite ne voterai pas ce bud à part
évidemment toujours quelques petites
distinctions mais je trouve qu'il y a eu
un marqueur évidemment un marqueur et là
où vous avez raison c'est que
aujourd'hui on en est à ça et je vois
bien que sur la question des retraites
c'est à peu près le même sujet il y a
quelque chose de très malhonnête
intellectuellement de la part de la
droite de dire qu'elle voterai peut-être
pas le texte de d'Emmanuel Macron de
cette majorité sur la question du de la
réforme des retraites mais je trouve
qu'il y a eu un manque et on voit bien
d'ailleurs comment se sont organisés les
choses la première ministre ou en tout
cas son cabinet a appelé quelques
présidents de groupes de l'Assemblée
nationale pas tous je trouve que en
termes de démocratie c'est quand même et
en termes de volonté de dialogue social
c'est quand même un peu compliqué quand
je dis pas tous évidemment ça veut dire
que la patronne de la France insoumise
et la patronne de rassemblance 5 minutes
[Musique]
contacter pourquoi pour savoir qui du
groupe Parti socialiste qui du groupe
EUROPE que les vertus du groupe LR
serait d'accord pour que le gouvernement
reprenne tel et tel amendement qui
aurait été voté par la majorité de
l'Assemblée nationale non quand Emmanuel
Macron Emmanuel Macron pardon quand je
crois Bruno Le Maire faisait le son sur
des questions de majorité minorité ce
serait eux qui auraient la majorité bon
ben dans ces ce qui a eu des textes
notamment le texte sur les dividendes de
la taxation des dividendes des
entreprises qui a été votée à la
majorité du parlement bien qu'il
reconnaisse qu'il y a eu une mise en
mise en minorité du gouvernement et là
pour la peine ils font la démonstration
s'ils reprennent cette demande qui a été
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale qui
sont vers la discussion et à minima
c'est quand même déjà un progrès c'est
il y a pas vraiment pas bon de l'amour
de gouvernement vis-à-vis
cet argument des oppositions qui disent
mais la majorité des députés
ont-elles mesures on ne comprendrait pas
pourquoi des mesures votées à la
majorité des députés ne figureraient pas
dans le texte final il y a plusieurs
choses un sur les sur les recettes il y
a des recettes indirectes il y a le
budget bien sûr mais il y a aussi
l'attractivité la compétitivité de la
France qui est au plus haut depuis
qu'Emmanuel Macron et au pouvoir le
chômage est au plus bas ce sont des
chiffres officiels vous pourrez les
vérifier c'est il y a beaucoup de
travailleurs pauvres et on essaye
évidemment de les sortir de la pauvreté
c'est une promesse de d'Emmanuel Macron
depuis son accession de pouvoir en 2017
mais quand vous regardez les chiffres
les indicateurs ils sont tous au vert
malgré le covid malgré la guerre en
Ukraine donc effectivement il y a moins
de recettes dans le budget mais nous on
compte aussi sur des recettes indirectes
et elles sont là donc ça on peut pas le
l'enlever au président de la République
ensuite sur sur les sur les oppositions
effectivement il y a parfois une entente
des oppositions mais je répète
malheureusement ce que je vous ai dit il
y a quelques minutes il faut un budget
clair un budget cohérent aujourd'hui
c'est un amendement déposé en plus par
un membre de la majorité et on peut le
regretter parce qu'il pourrait
correspondre à un budget qui n'est pas
celui d'aujourd'hui il pourrait
correspondre à un budget classique
aujourd'hui il y a un cadre il y a un
cadre budgétaire et Bruno Le Maire la
répéter on est dans un budget à l'euro
près et le modem sur cet amendement
malheureusement n'est pas dans ce cadre
budgétaire imposé par les circonstances
par la situation économique sinon on
pourrait mettre cette amendement mais on
dirait aux Français on va devoir
augmenter vos impôts c'est pas notre
promesse et Bonne Mère la répéter je ne
serai pas le ministre des Finances des
hausses d'impôts et Emmanuel Macron la
demander et la répéter pendant la
campagne présidentielle il n'y aura pas
de hausse d'impôts pour les Français
pendant mon quinquennat c'est cette
promesse que l'on doit tenir avec des
circonstances particulières ensuite sur
les oppositions faut-il les entendre
faut-il les écouter c'est ce qu'on a
fait quand vous avez Mathilde panneau
pour ne pas la citer la présidente de du
groupe François soumise à l'Assemblée
nationale elle a quitté les réunions à
Matignon au bout de 5 minutes en faisant
un coup de com en s'adressant aux
caméras elle a failli louper les micros
d'ailleurs tellement elle était pressée
de sortir du bureau d'Elisabeth borne
elle n'allait pas la rappeler plus tard
ce serait incohérent de sa part
sur la manière dont gouvernement gérer
49-3 le coup de là c'est un choix
politique d'attendre la fin des débats
avant de sortir ce 49-3 est-ce que vous
ne vous êtes pas retrouvé piéger
finalement vous misez peut-être sur une
obstruction parlementaire sauf que vous
avez eu des débats sur le fond avec des
mesures votées à la majorité par
plusieurs oppositions y compris par
votre majorité est-ce que vous êtes pas
retrouvé dans un piège politique non je
ne crois pas comme le disait d'ailleurs
pierre Jacquemin certains députés les
républicains de l'aile modérée sont dans
un jeu de dubs parce qu'il pourrait
voter ce budget tout comme des députés
socialistes modérés hors nupes qui
pourraient se reconnaître tout comme sur
la réforme des retraites certains
d'ailleurs reconnaissent une réforme qui
ressemble à celle de Laurence Rossignol
qui n'était pas dans la droite la plus
dure je crois au moment de sa réforme
des retraites donc on peut toujours
trouver des ententes des compromis c'est
ce qu'on a essayé de faire jusqu'au bout
qu'est-ce qu'on nous aurait dit rien
Mancini si on avait mis un 49-3 sur le
PLF sur le budget au premier jour des
débats vous êtes dans un simulacre de
démocratie vous êtes dans une dictature
et on appelle à prendre de la rue pour
combattre ça finalement on a exactement
les mêmes arguments mais au moins on a
eu l'expérience du dialogue et de la
majorité relative qui tente de retenir
des amendements de l'opposition c'est un
dialogue sain on essaiera d'aller
jusqu'au bout aujourd'hui on est forcé
de le constater dans une forme de
blocage lié au circonstances et comme le
disait Audrey le général de Gaulle a mis
cet outil à notre disposition le 49-3
pour éviter les blocages après il y a
une dimension qu'il ne faut pas ignorer
on n'est pas dans un 49-3 façon Michel
Rocca Manuel Valls pardon on est plutôt
dans un 49-3 façon Michel Rocard les
oppositions ont une arme ça s'appelle la
motion de censure vont-ils s'entendre
rassemblement national LFI c'est ce
qu'on verra dans les prochaines heures
mais à priori c'est quand même mais
est-ce que ça veut dire que vous
utiliserez le même procédé sur le budget
de la Sécurité sociale puisque son
examen demande demain à l'Assemblée
est-ce que là aussi vous laisserez les
débats aller jusqu'au bout où est-ce
qu'on a l'impression que vous avez quand
même des remontées de vos députés qui
disent on a un peu l'impression de
servir à rien c'est fatiguant tout ça
pour ça est-ce que du coup ça sera le
même processus sur le budget de la Sécu
je ne suis pas parlementaire je ne suis
pas membre du gouvernement c'est dans ce
Sénacle là qu'il faudra qu'il faudra en
décider remonter justement écouter les
remontées de de terrain remonter de de
l'Assemblée nationale des députés des
députés eux-mêmes et c'est dans ce
cadre-là que ce décidera ou non
l'utilisation d'un 49-3 pour la sécurité
sociale ça peut être le même processus
pierre selon vous est-ce que finalement
c'est bien que le gouvernement est lissé
les débats allaient jusqu'au bout est-ce
qu'il faut qu'il laisse les débats aller
jusqu'au bout également sur le budget de
la Sécurité sociale ou à priori ils
devraient aussi sortir la 43
que de toute façon a priori il y a pas
d'autres raisons que il y a pas d'autre
choix que le 49-3 et de laisser des
continuer de continuer les débats se
faire
dans un climat certes où on s'entend on
s'écoute souvent d'ailleurs la majorité
utilise des recours de de
des recours pour essayer de faire
éterniser les débats enfin bref tout ça
ni que ni tête et de toute façon on va
pas se raconter d'histoires le
gouvernement finira par faire passer son
texte de loi sur le budget donc il y a
pas de sujet ce qui risque de se passer
comment avec un risque
ni le Front national de votre handicte
respectifs donc le sujet c'est que ça
risque de crisper les parlementaires
mais au-delà les citoyens et on suivra
ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée
aujourd'hui puisque ça s'annonce
passionnant merci beaucoup d'être venu
vous restez avec nous on va regarder ce
qu'elle a une de
[Musique]